عندما تحدثنا في هذا الوقت من العام الماضي ،
تحدثنا عن اللوفر مع هل سنغير قواعد
اللعبة وليس هناك
شك في أنه كان عندما تفكر
في العام الماضي حيث نحن فيه
كان عامًا مزدحمًا للغاية بقدر ما تستطيع
تخيل أن لدينا أكثر من مليون
زائر في هذا المعرض بالذات 60 ٪ يأتون
من جميع أنحاء العالم و 40 ٪ قادمون
من سكان Yui ، لذا فإن القلق من
عدم وجود شهية للفن
والثقافة في أبو ظبي لا لا لا
لا لا لا على الإطلاق  لقد كان بالطبع مهمًا
للغاية وكل يوم نأتي بآلاف
الزوار ونفخر جدًا
بالتنوع الذي يأتي الناس من جميع أنحاء
العالم من المنطقة
بالطبع من نواة قوية جدًا
للناس في الصين عندما تحدثت لأول مرة إلى
محمد  إلمو باراك ،
رئيس قسم الثقافة والسياحة
هنا ، تحدث عن متحف اللوفر الذي
يوفر فرصة لتعكس
قيم قبول التسامح
للتواصل الثقافي كيف يفعل
المتحف ما نفعله مع
الأعمال الفنية التي
نقوم بها من خلال اقتراح أنك تعرف دانيال
أوك ، كل هذه الأشياء تظهر تأثيرات
التبادل أخبرني عن
عمليات الاستحواذ الجديدة والكتب الجديدة
التي نعرضها
الآن في الذكرى السنوية 11
عملية استحواذ جديدة ولكن هذا واحد  من
أكثرها إثارة للإعجاب ، إنه الجين الوحيد
، إنه بوذا ، آه ، إنه
عمل فني رائع من خشب Song Dynasty
نادر جدًا 12 حالة واحدة من
الحفظ ما يقول لك الزائرون
إنهم معجبون به ،
ترى أننا نقدم العديد  طبقات من
المتعة التي نقدمها ، هناك
متعة جسدية للعمل في هذا المكان
الذي له سبب صحيح ، لكنهم
أيضًا سعداء جدًا بمقابلة أعمال فنية من
هذه الصفات من جميع أنحاء العالم